this video is made possible by Vince
arrow watches luxury handcrafted watches
a fair prices you can check them out of
in Sarah watches comm /by graphics
there's also a link below his writings
inspired the great revolutionary
movements of the 20th century leading to
the dictatorial rise of men like Joseph
Stalin and Mao Zedong he lived a life of
poverty and obscurity contends let
others take the limelight and aware that
his ideas would not be realized during
his lifetime we remember him as the
father of communism yet the version that
took hold in the Soviet Union and China
wore little resemblance to what he had
envisions in this week's by graphics we
discover the man who was Karl Marx Karl
Marx was born on May the 5th 1818 in the
historic German town of Trier his was an
upper middle-class family with his
father Heinrich doing well as a lawyer
Carl's mother Henriette was from a
wealthy Dutch family the family was
Jewish but Heinrich had converted to
Christianity the year before Karl was
born in order to avoid the harsh laws
that were being imposed upon Jews Karl
was the third of nine children
he became the eldest son when his
brother Moritz died in 1919 the young
Karl was a lively child who was prone to
getting into trouble
he was home-schooled by his father to
the age of 12 at which point he entered
the tria high school third master of the
school Hugo wit and bark took an instant
liking to the inquisitive young Marx and
helped him to mold his early
philosophical ideas would embark taught
liberal ideas to his students and
employed young liberal humanists as
teachers as a result the school develops
a reputation as a fermenter of dangerous
ideologies in 1832 weten bark was placed
under surveillance by the authorities
with the school being searched for
subversive materials
[Music]
Carl graduated from the school at the
age of 17 he furthered his studies at
one University enrolling as law students
in October of 1835 he found the workload
during his first semester to be
extremely challenging by the beginning
of 1836 he had reduced his attendance to
a part-time level he spent most nights
at local pubs and often woke the next
day with a hangover limiting the amount
of focus that he could give to his
studies on one occasion he was actually
arrested for public intoxication after a
year of wasting his efforts at the
University of Bonn Marx's father he put
his foot down he transferred his wayward
son to the University of Berlin and
ordered him to start getting serious
about his education the summer before he
transferred to Berlin University called
returns home to tria
he began a romance with a young woman
called Jenny von Westphalen who he had
known since childhood before leaving for
university in October called proposed
and the two were engaged the move to
Berlin University has served the purpose
of encouraging Marx to get serious about
his studies he replaced late-night
carousing with membership in a number of
philosophical societies he became
interested in the ideas of German
philosopher GWF Hegel and the ideas that
he mulled over sore expression in a
number of essays and treatises that he
began working on calls bright academic
star it was diminished in May of 1838
with the death of his father he had a
great deal of respect and love the
heinrich UNS was shattered by his loss
his father had been supporting him
financially and the sudden loss of this
support imposed a financial hardship on
him this was a great concern to the West
farlands who were now convinced that
Karl would not be able to support their
daughter as his bride but the young
couple they continued their courtship
even though they were far away from each
other
following his father's death marks
shifted the focus of his studies from
law to philosophy his goal was to
graduate with honors and then secure a
position at the University is a
philosophy lecturer in order to help
fund his studies he sort work as a
journalist he secured a position with
the most controversial newspaper in the
region the rhineland news the paper
expressed with vocal opposition to the
Prussian occupation of the Rhineland in
October of 1842 Karl Marx became the
editor-in-chief of the paper it was
through this paper the marks began
writing about communism and what form a
possible communist government could take
but when he openly criticized the
Russian monarch Tsar Nicholas the first
there was a step too far
the brushing authorities moved in and
they shut down the paper Marx was now an
unemployed journalist but that didn't
stop him and Jenny marrying on June the
19th 1843 the ceremony took place in a
Protestant church and was attended by
members of both families though many of
the westfalen clan mutters that jenny
was marrying below her station however
the marriage it was to last a couple
until they were parted by death
Carl and Jenny they moved in with
Jenny's mother they lived off the
mothers step and as Carl tried to
restart his writing career he managed to
get a writing gig writing for a
newspaper called the Deutsche Franz oh
sure Yabba heard that had as its
audience far leftists in the Rhineland
the paper had been started by German
socialists Arnold Rouge who was based in
Paris in October of 1843
Marx and his wife they moved to Paris
and bordered with Rouge and his wife in
1844 Jenny gave birth to the first
Charles this made the living conditions
extremely cramped and sewed the Marx's
they moved into their own apartment as
well as publishing the newspaper Marx
Andrews worked together on two treatises
that would become very controversial the
second of them was called on the Jewish
Question
even though Marx was of Jewish ancestry
himself the pamphlet comes across as
quite anti-semitic in it he wrote for
the first time of the proletariat a
working-class band of revolutionaries
who would throw off the yoke of religion
and other cultural bonds to finally
unite the masses
soon after Marx moved on from working
with Rouge to find employment with the
paris-based newspaper
voorwarts or forward which targeted
Germans living in France the paper was
sponsored by the League of the just made
up of German immigrants who believed in
a communist system where everyone
enjoyed economic quality it was while
working for forwards that Marx met and
formed an alliance with Friedrich Engels
the two men they immediately gelled with
their ideas converging into what would
be called a classical Marxism Marx was
inspired by a report that angles had
written calls the conditions of the
working class in England he was
convinced more than ever that the
working class would eventually rise up
and overthrow their oppressors angles
came from a wealthy family and over the
years he would prop up Marx financially
time and time again their evolutionary
ideas that Marx was espousing through
his writings soon came to the attention
of the Prussian authorities who put
pressure on him to leave France the
interior ministry had shutdown forwards
and Marx was given 24 hours to leave the
country he decided to relocate to
Brussels Belgium with his wife and baby
joining him a few days later
[Music]
Belgium was a liberal and free-thinking
country and so it was a natural fit for
the leftist philosophies of Karl Marx
soon after settling in Brussels Jenny
became pregnant with a couple's second
child back in Germany Marx's
mother-in-law became concerns that her
daughter wouldn't be able to cope with
the stress of starting anew with one
small child and another one on the way
she sends her maid servant Helen DeMuth
to Brussels to help her cope Helen Wood
from then on be a permanent member of
the Marx household unknown to Marx the
Prussian government was putting crasher
on the Belgians to kick him out as a
result he experienced frustrating delays
in his efforts to obtain permanent
residency in order to get residency
granted he had to promise not to get
involved in local political issues or
espouse his political views he then
proceeded to find loopholes that would
allow him to spread his ideas in 1847 he
published a treatise entitled of a
poverty of philosophy which challenged
an earlier tract by French leftist
pierre-joseph Proudhon
called the philosophy of poverty the
poverty of philosophy was a stepping
stone towards Marx's most impressive and
famous work the Communist Manifesto in
order to get direct experience of the
conditions of the working class he
traveled to England in 1845 along with
Friedrich Engels they taught factories
and slums witnessing the terrible
working conditions and the even worse
living conditions after six weeks in
England marks returned to Brussels fully
equipped to produce his magnum opus two
weeks later the thirty page pamphlet it
was ready for the presses the communist
manifesto was published on February the
21st 1848 in it
mark stated that the bourgeoisie were
their own gravediggers with their
exploited workers rising up to ever
throw them
soon after the manifestos publication
the second French revolt broke out the
moniker was cast aside and the
Democratic government was put in place
back in Belgium Marx was arrested for
subversive activity upon his release he
made the decision to head to a
reinvigorated and freer France the
Marche family's relocation was helped by
the belated inheritance that he received
from his father's estate most of that
money though was poured into starting
another newspaper this newspaper was
called the Neue Rheinische Zeitung
angles worked on the paper providing the
latest news and happenings from europe
soon after moving to France Marx joins
the Communist League which had been
formed by members of the shock among
club after the Revolution in order to
prevent the aristocracy from reasserting
itself their methods of doing so were so
drastic that the time period became
known as the reign of terror
the French authorities viewed the
communist League as the reinstituted
Jacobin Club just under a new name
this brought official scrutiny upon the
league with Marx being arrested several
times initially the police were unable
to directly link him to any subversive
activity and no prosecution was brought
against him but things changed when the
Prussian King Frederick William the
fourth took a personal interest in
stomping out every leftist movement in
his realm it didn't take long phased
attention to go to the paris-based
leftist newspaper run by Karl Marx for
the second time in his life he was
expelled from France Marx had poured all
of his financial resources into the
paper with it shut down he was left with
nothing he only had enough money to get
out of France he had to visit a pawn
shop and hock his family's silver he
received support from a couple of German
socialists who raised money to help yet
marx reestablished however the help
turned out to be a double-edged sword
the benefactors have painted Marx to be
in such a poor demoralized condition in
order to secure support that karl was
treated as a laughingstock when he
returned Marx was not pleased with this
reception he stated that the greatest
financial difficulties are preferable to
public begging now just before we get
into Marx's move to London in his later
life I want to tell you a bit about
today's sponsor and that's been Sarah
watches I'm wearing a Vince arrow watch
right now this is a Vince arrow
chronograph and as well as keeping
perfect time it's also got a time you
see the three back dials there they look
great but they also serve the timer
function I picked out a watch with blue
and silver but there aren't loads of
options on their websites you'll be sure
to find something that suits your style
and your wrist size as I mentioned
before I have tiny Azure wrists say they
even sorted me out with a smaller model
and it fits perfectly I've had this
watch for a few months I took it on
holiday with me I've been putting it
through its paces and now I'm not a
super careful watch owner say the least
but it still looks in great condition
then Sarah watches believe that luxury
is all about price or specification it's
about detail and craftsmanship and even
Sarah watches they've got a ton of that
unlike many other watches on the market
and Sarah isn't about minimalist style
it's about the classic good look of a
watch which is something that I
personally love this is what really sets
it apart from others further by selling
direct to the consumer Vince Eric and
deliver a great watch at about a tenth
of the price that you might expect go
check out the full range oven Sarah
watches calm /nya graphics and use the
code bio graphics on check out for a
special discount and to help support
this show let's get back to marks
in June of 18-49 the Marx family of four
relocated yet again the destination this
time it was London England it was that
final move with the famous German
spending the rest of his life amongst
the English no long after the Marxist
settled in London the disbanded French
Communist League reformed in the city
the leaders of the movements wanted to
bring about an immediate revolt of the
working classes in London which would
ideally then spread across the entire
continent Marx viewed these goals as
unrealistic and labeled the leaders of
the Communist League as unrealistic
dreamers he was firmly convinced that
the overthrow would come but believed
that it had to evolve gradually he
wasn't even concerned if the revolution
didn't come in his own lifetime he was
happy to plant the seeds that would come
to fruition at a later time as it turned
out the first communist revolution it
didn't happen for another sixty-eight
years in London Marx focused on bringing
reforms on a smaller scale he championed
the rights of the poor and advocated for
voting rights and freedom of speech for
the first few months in London the Marx
family were among the poor of London
only surviving thanks to the financial
support provided by Friedrich angles the
financial strain it was lifted in 1851
when Marx secured a position as a
European correspondent for the New York
Daily Tribune at the start angles had to
translate the Articles that Marx wrote
before long Karl taught himself English
and was able to translate for himself at
the time the New York Daily Tribune was
the most widely read newspaper in all of
the United States the paper paid in 200
pounds per year
in order to provide two articles per
week still it was never quite enough and
the family struggled to make ends meet
in 1852 Marx was concerned with what was
taking place across the English Channel
the second French Revolution had erupted
and a new Napoleon the nephew of the
first seized power establishing himself
as the new emperor Marx was frustrated
at how the French working people could
allow another dictator to rule over them
he wrote a book called the eighteenth
Brumaire of Louie Napoleon which mocks
the new emperor in it he placed the
blame on both the French working-class
for the sucked in by the dictator and on
the proletariat being gullible to
napoleon's promised to keep the masses
in check in his book he summed it up
this way the struggle seems to be
settled in such a way that all classes
equally impotence and equally remote
fall on their knees before the rifle but
as a correspondent for the New York
Daily Tribune Marx was in a unique
position to give an outside perspective
on the American Civil War he predicted
that the election of Abraham Lincoln
would lead to civil war and that the war
would greatly impact the British economy
with its textile industry relying on
exports of cotton from the American
South
he was right on both counts with the
slowdown in trade being termed the
cotton famine many British factory
workers lost their jobs providing the
British government with the incentive to
provide financial aid to prop up the
Confederate cause Marx was quick to
point out the hypocrisy in Britain's
position having outlawed slavery itself
Britain was now supporting the slave
owning southern states in order to boost
her own economy his articles were
published in the Tribune
without the senton tilt the paper
changed its Pro abolitionist stance and
began calling for an immediate cessation
of hostilities from now on articles had
to be neutral in their tone this was a
disaster for Marx Eve unwilling to
compromise his principles tendered his
resignation
once more Karl Marx was unemployed it
was terrible timing with financial
pressures having mounted even before his
leaving the paper on top of that jenny
was sick with a bout of smallpox with
nowhere else to turn
Marx sought relief from Friedrich Engels
however bengal's was grieving the recent
death of his wife and the letter from
Karl requesting relief was not taken
kindly after three days of stewing on
the matter
he sent the following reply you will
find it natural that my own trouble and
your frosty reception of it made it
positively impossible for me to answer
you earlier all my friends have shown me
on this occasion which was bound to
touch me very nearly more sympathy and
friendship than I could expect you found
the moment suitable to enforce the
superiority of your cold thought
processes Marx was surprised and upset
that he had unwittingly insulted angles
he quickly wrote back in the process
giving us insight into just how
desperate his situation was he wrote my
wife and children will bear me witness
that when your letter came I was much
shattered by the death as one of those
nearest to me but when I wrote to you in
the evening it was under the impression
of very desperate conditions
I had the landlord's broker in the house
the butcher protesting might check
shortage of coals and food and little
Jenny in bed in such circumstances
as I can generally save myself only by
cynicism
the two men quickly made up in angles
once more provided financial support to
keep the Marx family afloat before long
however Marx faced a new crisis while
his wife's health improved his urn began
to deteriorate balls erupted all over
his body of causing great pain and
discomfort he suffered on as he
completed his latest work dust capital
the work was published in Berlin in 1867
in it he emphasised the surplus value of
labour and the impact that machines
would have on the workforce does capital
was a success but that didn't translate
to financial stability for the ever
struggling family Marx's mother once
made the salient comment if only Karl
had made capital instead of just writing
about it when Marx's daughter Laura got
engaged to a struggling medical students
named Paul Lafargue her protective
father sought to save her from the same
mistake mother had made marrying a man
who was ill-prepared to Cather her he
strongly objected to the marriage only
relenting when he gained the assurance
that the young man was able to care for
his daughter financially by 1869 marx
was actively working as an ambassador
for an organization called International
workingmen's association which
endeavoured to bring the world of
communism together under a single
umbrella in 1870 France declared war on
Germany among the International
workingmen's association there was a
division between those who were in favor
of the war and those who were against it
Marx was keen for Germany to give the
French a good drubbing
believing that it would lead to the
resurgence of socialism in France
following the defeat of Napoleon the
third a coalition of international
workers members and French citizens
combined to take control of Paris after
two months they were overthrown by the
French authorities in that short period
of time Marx saw the embodiment of his
proletarian revolt its overthrow by the
establishment convinced him that the
working class can't simply lay hold of
ready-made state machinery and wield it
for its own purposes for a takeover of
power to be successful Marx reasons
there had to be an existing
infrastructure ready to replace the old
one
for the last decade of his life Karl
Marx struggled with health problems and
financial survival during this period he
produced just one work of notes in which
he commented on what he terms the
dictatorship of the proletariat he
expressed his firm belief that the
masses needed to work together in the
coming revolution without allowing for a
dominant leader to rise
unfortunately that is precisely what
happens in many of the communist
revolutions of the 20th century on
December the 2nd 1881 Karl's lifelong
companion Jenny died she had been in
terrible pain with cancer of the liver
for months her last words to call were
good indicating that she was happy that
her pain was at an end following Jenny's
death Marx fell into a deep depression
at the prompting of his lifelong friend
Friedrich angles he took a holiday to
Algiers after two months he returned to
England just as he was beginning to get
back on his feet he received another
blow when his daughter Jenny Caroline
died of bladder cancer at the age of 38
with the loss of his tube Jenny's Marx
gave up the will to live he hung on for
another two months wracked by pain and
living in poverty the end game on March
the 14th 1883 when his body succumbed to
a combination of bronchitis and pleurisy
the man was gone but his ideas continued
and they had a massive impact on the
coming century so I really hope you
found their video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe also check out
our fantastic sponsor Vince arrow
watches you'll find a link to them below
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]